that's Matt by and political writer for
The New York Times Magazine and author
of the book the argument billionaire
bloggers battle to remake democratic
politics I was born and grew up in
Trumbull Connecticut which is a little
town just outside Bridgeport I think
anybody who spending time in Bridgeport
it's not far from here makes me a Yankee
fan you know but I think anyone has
spent any time in Bridgeport or in many
of the industrial cities in the
Northeast would understand how you know
where my worldview was formed because
you know for me I grew up around in
pockets of affluence huddled around
these old great industrial cities that
were just rotting and that were unsafe
and that were uninhabitable and where
and where the economies and the social
order had fallen into great sort of
chaotic disrepair and and I was always
told there were places you could go and
there were places your current you
couldn't so I could take the train in
new york city and i could see Yankee
Stadium from the train but you never got
out in Harlem because lord knows what
would happen if you got out in Harlem
and I grew up wondering why you couldn't
go to those places and what had created
those conditions and as soon as I was
you know started again to journalism
that's where I went I went to the first
to the South Bronx than to and ending at
the Boston Globe owes and covered the
projects in boston and i'm often
somebody asked me recently i won't go on
and on with all questions but this one
matters to me somebody asked me recently
I didn't I did an interview with a book
site and they said what writers
influenced you you know and I had to
think about it for a while and I finally
said you know it's not political book so
I can't think of many political books
that have been influential to me but
novelists who one who have understood
much better than non fiction writers and
journalists have the condition of sort
of dying industrial America and what it
means to us as a country and so you know
people like Richard Russo who writes
about this over and over again and
Philip Roth throughout American pastoral
and you know people who you know who
captured this moment at the end of the
industrial age that you know sort of
defines where we are so I grew up right
in the heart of that moment